hello everyone and welcome to a game
with a really really wonderful tactical
solution yeah it's uh magnus carlsen
versus jordan palm forest and it's round
one of the chesable masters the
preliminaries uh it's uh well it's a
very quick game but uh you guys will
enjoy this one uh hopefully as that's
why we we kind of show the games on this
channel uh so magnus has the white
pieces and he opens with d4 we have d5
by jordan at c for e6 knight to c3 and
c5 now going for the taj defense c
captures on e5 we have e captures and
knight to f3 we have knight to f6 and
bishop to g5
so this is all very very standard stuff
uh bishop to e6 uh you're in continuous
development and now that d captures on
c5 b a bishop captures on f6 is also
playable e3 is also playable so you can
continue developing or you can play
forcing lines if you know uh
how to play them and of course magnus
does bishop captures on c5 e3 and now
knight to c6 we have bishop to b5
pinning the knight uh and here there are
a couple of known moves in classical
chess for example castle season on move
a6 is unknown but the move uh jordan
plays h6 is a new move so already as of
move nine we have a completely new game
now magnus captures on f6 we have queen
captures uh jordan gets to develop his
queen very nicely here but there's the
problem of the d5 pawn why is the pawn
not defended
well magnus captures it and he asks
jordan why is your pawn not defended and
jordan says well because i want to
capture on b2 and that's a very very
brave decision now probably the soundest
option for for jordan is just captures
here and after queen captures the bishop
to be for check
will pose some problems for magnus but
after king to f1
uh he will have a very very nice
attacking setup he can even play h4 in
the future maybe even play rook h3 rogue
g3 if you're in castle's king's side so
this would be one way to do it but
jordan captures on v2 and now it's
magnus to move and here he goes for the
instant knight to c7 with check now it
seems like uh
uh seems like it doesn't matter whether
you go knight to c7 check first or
bishop captures and c6 check but here it
kind of does
because if you capture first then it's
uh it's forced this comes with check and
after b captures knight to c7 also comes
with check the queen is controlling the
d file so you have to move the king
either to f8 or to e7 but it's better to
e7 because we also want to get the king
sidewalk into the game now castles we
don't want to grab the rook and face
bishop to b for check and now after rook
8 to d8 attacking the queen queen a4 and
the black is completely busted that's uh
there's not all that much you can do
here the pawn is hanging let's say you
defended queen b6 we're gonna play
knight captures on e6 and after f
captures knight to e5 and it's just a
terrible terrible position the knights
the g6 is being threatened knight
captures on c6 everything is just
hanging and you will not be able to play
this but okay this is rapid chess magnus
goes for knight to c7 check first and
now it's a little bit different because
now after king to e7 uh you don't really
have uh bishop captures this will not
come with check if you play this to get
the exact same position then we already
move into a completely different line
where black is much more active so
instead we have castles here and after
king to e7 magnus doesn't want to
see this bishop to be for check with his
king on e1 still
rook 8 to d8 attacking the queen and now
just queen to c1 magnus offers a queen
trade claiming that he will have a much
better end game so here are queen
captures with rook captures on c1 and
now king to d6 and it seems like uh
up until this point it was uh still
still playable but after king to d6
magnus is now completely winning but you
have to really really uh spot why and
this is not an easy one uh so feel free
to pause the video here uh and find the
solution to this one while i give you a
couple of seconds you will enjoy it
if you find it and you will be very very
happy with yourself so
have at it
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting that you
can win material while uh defending uh
mate on the back rank and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is the very forcing knight captures an
e6 now of course the pawn has to capture
if the king captures then we just grab
the free bishop so f captures on e6 now
rook f the d1 with check trying to get
the king away from the defense of the
bishop on c5 and after king to c7 first
we eliminated the rook here uh
capture 78 and now rook captures on c5
and all of this
you have to keep in mind that rook to d1
is a terrible threat however if black
delivers this check we can always block
with bishop to f1 so we're not getting
checkmated we are up a full piece and of
course we are winning the game but there
is one great move for jordan here as
well and that uh is uh sorry after rook
captures on c5 uh king to b6 attacking
the bishop ended the rook and now if
magnus wants to keep an eye on the
bishop he has to move the rook all the
way here and jordan will attack it with
the g6 and now you have to move the rook
and jordan wins back the piece for
example captures captures and now g4
trying to
not get checkmated and okay next you're
gonna push h4 grab this pawn will
continue pushing and the white will most
likely win this however magnus goes for
the absolute cleanest way and that is
rook captures on c6 with check so he
prefers the two pieces for the rook uh
solution b captures on c6 and now uh
bishop to a4 now you are defending
checkmate as you're controlling the d1
square and there really isn't all that
much black can do here yes both have
five pawns but the knight and bishop are
much much superior to the rook uh also
uh magnus has two pawn islands whereas
jordan has four pawn islands uh as you
can
as you can see here so c5 jordan of
course will still continue playing this
knight to e5 and king to c7 we have came
to f1 so now you don't have to worry
about getting checkmated rook to d2 a
very active uh move with the rook and
bishop to b3 guarding the a2 pawn rook
to beat you and now uh ponta h4 uh we
have rook to b1 check king e2 king to d6
now and f4 just defending the knight so
this is not the easier part of the game
for magnus rook to be to check king f3
rook to b1 and now pawn to g4 now the
pawns are marching forward on the king
side and the pass pawn will soon be
created rook to c1 we have g5 king to e7
uh and now king to g4 we have rook to e1
going after the e3 pawn but magnus says
you can have that one i am going to
gobble up all of these pawns so king h5
rook captures an e3 king to g6 and now h
captures on g5
adjust h captures we have king to f8 and
now knight to d7 with check going after
the c5 pawn uh you you defend this one
but then you give up this one it's
impossible to keep an eye on everything
king back to e7 knight captures on c5
and now as this pawn is also being
attacked twice uh just e5 but magnus
advances the f pawn so king to d6 we
have knights to e6 going after the g7
pawn e4 and king captures and g7 we have
rook to f3 and now just f6 the knight is
defended so you can just start pushing
your pawns uh e3 uh jordan also starts
pushing his pass pawn but not knight to
d4 and he was in this position on mu 41
that jordan puffer has resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so really really a a wonderful wonderful
game uh there were many many
possibilities for both magnus and jordan
but that
uh solution after king to d6
with that beautiful forcing line uh
getting magnus two pieces for the rook
uh and the just the winning end game was
uh obviously the
simplest way for magnus to do it and
that's how he did it but here you resign
because after anything we're just gonna
push f7 and well there's no stopping f8
uh
if you push the pawn we can simply
capture it with the knight if you
capture we promote to a queen and other
than that you really have nothing you
can play king
king to e7 but now again pretty much
anything we can just play g6 move the
king push g7 and g8 so really
absolutely everything wins here there's
no counter play for black
so after knight to d4 jordan resigned
and what a great victory for magnus uh
king to d6 and now i mean this is this
is one definitely for the books and also
if you guys want to uh you know memorize
it or print screen it or even print it
you know so you can share it with
everyone that is up to you
so yeah once again hope you guys enjoyed
it this is only the first game that
we're covering uh from day one of the
chestable masters so if you guys have
any of your favorites do use hashtag
suggestion and we will go over them uh i
would like to thank david kimura john
guilfoyle dominic novieli adam rosenberg
and francis ayer for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing uh the coverage of the
chesapeal masters until it ends uh so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day